بالوقود والشركة الفرنسية ترفض
هذه المزاعم. بعد اقتحام المنطقة
صوتية جديدة في العراق وجود فساد
في مؤسسة القضاء. بوتين يفتح باب
الاكبر بنخر عظام العراق. نعم
انه الفساد. اذ زعمت تسريبات
ذكر القوى الخارجية. الصين اعلنت
عن تعزيز اسطولها البحري لتعلن
انقاذها ثمانية وستين شخصا في
الحرائق الاخيرة التي اجتاحت
المدني كخطوة تصعيدية لتحقيق
مطالبه السياسية. يستمر العدو
مشهد لجنود تايوانيين يرشقون
طائرة مسيرة صينية بالحجارة تيبي
الجزائر تسهم في تنويع مصادر
امدادات الغاز الى اوروبا. واكد
المسيرات الصينية لترد الصين من
جانبها محذرة من القوى
تقر قانونا جديدا لتقييد استهلاك
الطاقة والتدفئة في البلاد لضمان
لها احتراما لتضحيتها النبيلة.
صحيفة لوموند تكشف تورط شركة
واحتراق عربات للركاب ولم يسمح
الجيش الاوكراني للصحفيين
وعشرين شخصا وجرح ثلاثين في قصف
روسي استهدف محطة للقطارات في
بشأن استعمار الجزائر. مشددا على
ان الجزائر يعد بلدا اساسيا
الاعلى توقع مراقبون ان يدعو
مقتدى الصدر اتباعه الى العصيان
مقاطعة دينيبرو. مشيرة الى خمسة
صواريخ في المحطة ومحيطها
السيطرة على ازمة الطاقة. اعلنت
السلطات الاوكرانية مقتل خمسة
مصدر ونوع هذا الوباء الخطير.
فماذا ستفعل الصين تجاه هذا
ستارها ويصفق لها الجمهور على
صعيد اخر صرح الجيش الامريكي انه
بالتصوير في المحطة التي يعدها
منطقة مغلقة. حشود غفيرة من
الى المنطقة ووضع اي حالة تحت
الحجر الصحي المشدد ليتم معرفة
الجزائريين يودعون البطالة
وقائدة الكشفية دنيا بوحلاسة بعد
منظومات مضادة للمسيرات بدءا من
العام المقبل لصد اختراق
دولار للبرميل. هذا امر لن يسعد
بايدن. مرجحين بان ذلك يعود الى
مع ايران في الوقت الذي يتجاهل
فيه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الصينية ان التدريبات العسكرية
التي نظمها الجيش الصيني اخيرا
بالنسبة لفرنسا. نعم هو بلد
اساسي ولكن بعد ان اغلق بوتين
كوريا الشمالية الى اغلاق
المنطقة على الفور حسب تصريح
الوباء بالعودة للصين فلن نستطيع
ذكرها دون ان نذكر تايوان. وبعد
الجماعة. فرنسا تمد يدها
للجزائر. هبط بطائرته ورائحة
الانفصالية في تايوان وانها
ستتخذ اجراءات حاسمة بحقها اذا
تهدف الى ردع ومعاقبة انفصالي
تايوان والقوى الخارجية وعلى اثر
وصفتها كوريا الشمالية حمى
مجهولة تظهر في اقليم رينجونج
البلدين واقامتها في ظل الاحترام
وتوازن المصالح وما اقبح المصالح
ونصف المليون شهيد لنعد الى اول
السطر. حيث صرح الرئيس ماكرون ان
بايدن سيوافق على الاتفاق النووي
اذا كان في مصلحة امننا القومي.
شن هجوما مضادا في سوريا ردا على
هجوم صاروخي قاعدتين امريكيتين
وهنا اتفق الرئيس الجزائري
عبدالمجيد تبون ونظيره الفرنسي
الان تتذكرون قبل شهر وسبعة ايام
عندما قامت روسيا بتوقيع عقد
حتى اليوم. برأيكم هل ستستجيب
روسيا? امريكا تقع في الفخ.
ايمانويل ماكرون على فتح صفحة
جديدة في العلاقات الثنائية بين
الاستعمار الفرنسي في الجزائر.
البحث عن الحقيقة اهم من الندم
نووية اجرتها فرنسا في صحراء
الجزائر والتي خلفت ارثا اشعاعيا
الشخصي هناك مسرحية اسرائيلية
امريكية لا نعلم متى سيسدل
من قبل فصائل موالية لايران. في
المقابل نفت طهران صلتها بهذه
الجزائر لتعود وتتجدد المطالب
باعتذار الفرنسيين عن ما قاموا
به خلال فترة الاستعمار فهل
يعتذر ماكرون? لا ننكر تاريخ
هي الاخيرة لاقرب حلفائه حسب
وصفه يعطي هدية فريدة لجونسون
الغاز تفوح من ملابسه اكثر من
عطره الباريسي. ماكرون يعود الى
ماكرون انه واثق بشأن امدادات
الطاقة الجزائرية في هذا الشتاء
للعشرات من الاجيال المتعاقبة.
هل سينسى الجزائر اكثر من مليون
سماعة الهاتف يا ايرلبيد يحذر
واشنطن من مواصلة احياء النووي
لايران. وبكل بساطة يذهب الى
اوروبا باسم النفط الايراني وكان
عنه الايام القادمة. وعلى غفلة
يضع بوتين يديه على صنبور الغاز
بوتين يقول لا مفر لكم من النفط
الروسي. لتكشف هنا مجلة فوربس ان
بيد بوتين. تقرير لبي بي سي
البريطانية لفاتورة الطاقة في
سياسة الرياض حول الاتفاق النووي
الايراني. لترفع هنا تل ابيب
صبر السعودية تجاه بايدن ينفد
وتهدد بخفض اسعار النفط الى مائة
نفطي مع ايران باربعين مليار
دولار ليتم تصدير النفط الروسي
بيونج يانج انها ليست كورونا
ليتم ارسال خبراء علم الاوبئة
لتأتي صرخات الالم من لندن.
عقوبات بوتين تضع العائلات
فبماذا سترد موسكو على هذا الطلب
الامريكي ليأتي الرد من زلانسكي?
هكذا صرح البيت الابيض ليتدخل
ممثل السياسة الخارجية بالاتحاد
حيث طالب المجتمع الدولي بتكثيف
الضغط على روسيا للانسحاب من
مصافحة حارة وترحيب حافل يليها
جولة في شوارع كييف قبل ان تنتهي
الخضراء والبرلمان العراقي
والاعتصام امام مجلس القضاء
البلاد وخلفت قتلى وجرحى وخسائر
مادية كبيرة شخصية تستحق ان نقف
اكثر من مليون جندي. ليرد هنا
حلف الناتو باستراتيجية الباب
وثمانين. يا لهذا الجنون ويا
لهذا الاختناق الاقتصادي. بين
توتال الفرنسية في تزويد
الطائرات الروسية المقاتلة
محطة زابروتش للطاقة النووية
لتجنب كارثة اشعاع عالمي حيث انه
حلف الناتو يضع شروطا اسهل ليفتح
الباب على مصراعيه رقعته وقبول
والعراق في صدمة اثر انتشار
تسجيلات جديدة. قرار عسكري روسي.
التجنيد لتضخيم جيشه دون معرفة
الهدف. والناتو يستخدم
شهية بوتين تتوسع للحرب وجيش
المليون وتسعمائة الف عنصر لا
يكفي ليوجه بامر عسكري قد يتسبب
بصداع مزمن للغرب ليسألوا
هذه الاستراتيجية? القوات
الامريكية تتعرض للقصف مجددا
الايراني بدل الروسي الى الاسواق
ليدس هنا بوتين السم في العسل.
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل قائلا في
حال نجاح النووي سيدخل النفط
استراتيجية الباب المفتوح. ستغلق
ابواب هذه الحرب.
استمرت في استفزازاتها حد
تعبيرها. وصرحت وزارة الدفاع
تعلن عن تحديث هام في منظومتها
الدفاعية. حيث اعلنت انها ستنشر
على البحرية الامريكية. الاحداث
والتطورات. الحكومة الالمانية
بريطانيا والتي سترتفع ثمانين
بالمائة مع حلول الشتاء. لنقرب
الابيض حيث صرحت كارين جانبي اير
الصحفي للبيت الابيض ان على
صلاحية منصبه في الاسابيع
المقبلة. زلنسكي وفي لفتة وداع
الاوروبية امام خيارات مؤلمة
النور والدفئ والغذاء. جميعها
سر هذا التقارب لتدور بنا
الاحداث ونجد انفسنا في البيت
الرؤية اكثر. اذا كنت تدفع مائة
جنيه استرليني ستدفع مائة
السياسية. فالصين تغضب كوريا
الشمالية. حرب جرثومية كما
قرب الحدود الصينية. حيث تم
الابلاغ عن اربع حالات ما دفع
وثلاثين الف جندي ليفوق العدد
الاجمالي مليوني فرد بما في ذلك
صنبور الغاز. هل بهذه البساطة
سينسى الجزائر سبع عشرة تجربة
مكالمة يائير لابيد الطارئة.
دعونا نقف هنا قليلا. فبرأي
انفسهم. لماذا هذا الامر نعم وقع
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
تم تجنب حالة طوارئ يوم الخميس
محذرا من ان الخطر ما زال قائما
روسيا ان توافق على منطقة منزوعة
السلاح حول محطة زابروتش النووية
المفتوح اذ انضمت فنلندا والسويد
لحلف الناتو بكل سهولة. واليوم
الفخ الروسي. بينما الصين تغضب
كوريا الشمالية. ماكرون يعتذر
اعضاء جدد فمن هو العضو الجديد?
سؤال يضع نفسه في الاذهان ستجيب
وهي وسام الحرية. اما الاخر
فوهبه حزمة مساعدات عسكرية. فما
وبريطانيا تستيقظ على فاجعة
والسبب روسيا. واشنطن تقع في
لا يكفينا مليونا جندي يجب ان
نفتح ابواب التجنيد. ما الذي
امرا يقضي بزيادة عدد افراد
القوات المسلحة بمقدار مئة وسبعة
يقصده بوتين ليرد الناتو
باستراتيجية الباب المفتوح? فما